hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Saturday here is the game a
couple of you have requested it in the
comment section a game from the forth
titled leeches arena now as you all know
cause someone the first three titled
arenas at leeches and the prize fund for
for the fourth title arena was three
thousand and two hundred dollars now
every time Carlson won the titled arena
he donated the money back to leeches so
I believe I haven't read anywhere but I
believe it was the same this time as a
lot of people are joking that this
leeches arena is like cousins personal
bank accounts he just wins the donates
it back and then after maybe he wins it
like 20 times only then will he like
take the money when the prize fund will
be like maybe twenty or thirty thousand
dollars but either way he's playing
against a person named the night King
and I have no idea who this person is
he's a grandmaster I do know that but I
don't know his identity so as usual
there's the hoodie guy again only this
time as his nickname is the night King I
decided to use an actual photo of the
night king yes I'm a big Game of Thrones
fan and as usual in honor of the hoodie
guy I am doing this video in a hoodie as
the hoodie guy always loses the greatest
of games for for our pleasure
so before before I show you the game
here is the the table of the final
standings in this tournament as you can
see dr. drankin Stein as that magnus
carlsen human first place clever tactics
but fail also a grandmaster as you can
see in second place and the night king
96 his opponent from this game won third
place so all random or all three of them
are grandmasters and you can see Causton
finished the tournament with an
excellent performance of three thousand
and twelve so very nice 65 games planned
and the win rate of 75 percent those are
some excellent stats so the reason i
just had to show you this game is
because it's quite a nice game involving
involving a lot of tactics so a nice
game for for a Saturday and it does
contain two positions which you will be
able to solve so basically it's a it's a
it's a game but also maybe a weekend
puzzle so let's check it out
has the white pieces and he opens with
c4 so the English opening Knight to f6
g3 we have a b6 and Bishop to g2 so
immediately going for the rookin 8a
Knight to c6 blocking d4 obviously
preparing d5 now e6 and the immediate d5
pawn captures pawn captures Knight has
to move Knight to e5 and Knight to c3
we have Bishop to d6 and this is a this
is a weird move or obviously Bishop to
b4 was was somewhat better this comes
with the idea of maybe later playing
something like c6 and then finding a
nice square for the bishop here but here
this gives Carlsen the opportunity to
immediately go after this knight on e5
so f4 knife comes to c4 and here a
constant constant has a lot of good
moves he can go if he can go efore
threaten a5 and it which is basically
the reason why black decided he doesn't
want to go to g6 after Carson play
therefore if you want g6 then d4 I don't
want to have so many pieces in front of
all of these all of these strong
connected pawns in the center so Knight
to c4 and here a cousin can simply
continue e4 maybe Queen to a4 attack the
knight but he plays b3 as this is a
bullet game you want to give your
opponent as many opportunities as you
can for him to make a mistake and also
we want to make him and make all the
decisions all the time so probably the
best move even if it's not really the
best move for this time form it
definitely is the best move so attacking
the knight and here moving the Knight to
a5 would be a poor move white and simply
continue if I was a threat now we have a
silly night here so instead Bishop to b4
attacking cousins undefended knight on
c3 what do you do here so Queen to d3 24
might have been a bit better as bishop
basics will be able to harass the Queen
on d3 later but you know such things are
rarely rarely seen in in such fast games
Knight to d6
getting the night out of the way and now
nice to h3 our cousin
I mean 19 castles crossing castles and
now a5
making room for this bishop to come to a
6 as the rook will now be protecting it
we have nice 2 F 2 bishop now comes to
a6 and now Queen to c2 rook to e8 now
there's a double attack on d2 pawn from
the bishop and orokin e8 budget captures
on c3 will be a threat so the pawn can
be captured
Carson plays rook to e1 kind of now
protecting it three times with the
Knight Queen and the rook but also this
is a pawn sacrifice which night King
accepts so we have Bishop captures Queen
captures and now rook captures on you
two
rook captures Bishop captures and now
Bishop to b2 so a knight King just
grabbed a pawn but Crossland has this
powerful Bishop Queen battery that's I'm
the g7 square so this knife can't move
and lock does have to find some some
sort of a plan and it's it's not the
easiest thing to do when you're in time
trouble so basically it's better to give
up a pawn when you're in time trouble
and have this beautiful Queen Bishop
battery and then to be and then to you
know have to figure out a plan for black
so a for cousin plays rook to e1
attacking the bishop on e2 and now a 3
and I think would very much enjoy
exchanging this very strong bishop for
this light square bishop that's
currently not really doing all that much
Bishop to a1 of course Carlson will not
accept this this trade and the bishop
back to a6 and now comes Knight to g4
attacking this this guy here of course
you can never capture it because Queen
to g7 would be game over immediately
so after Knight g4 Knight bTW e8 so
guarding the f6 Knight but also maybe
guarding g7 not really because if you
have removed this night then rook
captures on e8 will be a threat simply
removing the defender of the g7 square
which tempo so we have d6 here an
excellent move the only move that gives
Y the advantage as this opens up the
attack from the bishop to the rook and
you have to react to this obviously if
you now capture the night then the idea
we just spoke of comes to mind row
capture screen captures and now again
when captors on g7 is checkmate so after
this night dt8 and d6 c6 was played and
here cousin played h3 h3 was was kind of
a kind of a slow move because here you
actually have a rook to e7 and this is
one of the reasons I decided to show
this game it doesn't matter if they a
both of them is this move it's below the
game you know of course you're not
expected to find it everything but it's
very interesting what happens again of
course you can't capture the knight here
because again rook captures ne8 will
finish the game but it's interesting
because of Knight captures on d6 now you
eliminate the d6 pawn and Queen captures
on e7 is now a threat but now you get
Knight captures on f6g captures on f6
and Queen captures on f6 and now it's
actually a forced checkmate in three
whatever black does but it's interesting
after black defense would come to f8 so
now you don't have queen to h8 as king
will capture it's actually again a force
made in 3 but it's it's a very very nice
checkmate so post post the video here
and trying to find the force checkmate
in three there are a lot of moves here
that actually went but there are only
only two ideas that win in three moves
and basically that that's the beautiful
part and both both of these ideas are
pretty much based on the same theme so I
will give a couple of seconds feel free
to pause and find the move so I do hope
you were successful if you did
congratulations you're an excellent
player and if you're just you know maybe
want to enjoy the show
the idea is Bishop to h3 Bishop to h3 or
f5 both of these moves are played with
the idea of controlling the e6 square
why is this so important well let's say
better to h3 now you control these six
square and what does black play here of
course if you capture then Queen 2hh
this is immediate to checkmate because
the queen is now blocking the King's
path to e7
the thing is black doesn't have a move
here whatever whatever you play white
will play Queen to h8 check of course
there's really no way to prevent this I
mean whatever you play any move
whatsoever then comes Queen - agh check
King now captures and now you see the
importance of the cover d6 square now
Bush to f6 will be checkmate
so a very nice position I mean I know
it's you can win it in a whole lot of
different ways but you know that's
that's the beauty of solving a chess
past we have to do it in as less moves
as possible at least you know but okay
after d6 c6 we have a ch3 Carlsen didn't
go for rook to e7 now Knight captures
and now Queen to d4 Knight texts Queen
on d4 Queen to e5 and now comes Knight
captures on g3 so across in kind of a
spot his position but still he has this
powerful Queen Bishop queen battery and
that's very hard to deal with Knight
captures on f6 we have pawn captures and
now Queen - Queen to e3 attacking the
knight Knight to a5 attacking the Queen
Queen three four and now Knight to g7
and here calls and pushes f5 of course
he wants the he wants to play either
Queen to g4 or Queen to h4 depending on
what black plays here
Knight King played Queen to e8 and now
cousin has this very nice Queen to h4
that gets the Queen out of the way he
doesn't want to trade Queens and also
guards the rook anyone that is now
attacking the Queen Queen to f8 and now
Bishop captures on f6 here the only way
for black to actually continue playing
this game is Bishop to d3 a Bishop to d3
is a move that you would find maybe not
even in a in a classical game let alone
in such a low time format would the idea
that you want the the real threat is
here is rook to e3 rook to g3 and then
you have a winning
attack on g7 but the idea of Bishop to
d3
is now that rook to e3 is met with
Bishop captures on f5 and this is met
with Bishop to g6 but it doesn't matter
you don't have to make a roof left you
can simply play Queen to g5 protected
this guy and only then make a roof lift
and then you know you'd have to play
something like h6 Queen captures and
only then capture here but it would
still be a winning attack for
white in in the long run so after this
Bishop captures on f6 Knight King played
Queen to c5 check King to h2 and now
rook to e8 rook to e8 is the final
losing move and here is the second
puzzle of the of this video and it's an
even better one than the first one so
here we have mate in 3 try to find it
and when you know Carson they find it in
like a few seconds but you know give it
a couple of more seconds because you
could easily miss it
as it's you know it's not not that
immediately immediately all that clear
so I do hope you pause the video and try
to solve it I will give you a couple of
more seconds you know just in case for
you to decide that's okay for those of
you who who did find the move
congratulations you are once again an
excellent player and for those who just
want to enjoy the show if you found
Queen to g5 with the idea of twin g7
checkmate then you would not win this
game brilliantly as Carson did because
now black has Queen d6 check and now
what do you do if you go king h1 King g1
you lose the rock with chick
if you play Queen g3 black simply
exchange your squints and then grab your
rock anyone so you only move you have
here as White is actually route 25 and
here black can capture your rope with
check you have to capture back and now
drop captures here and I will have a
bishop rook and the night against the
Queen and this bishop and you do have a
whole lot of points so white is still
better here but you would not you know
be be winning this game in three moves
like we've said so after rook to e8 the
movie you had to find is not Queen to g5
but rather Queen to g3
and now black is lost there is no more
Queen to d6 check it's very simple but
you know in in time trouble you could
easily make this mistake of playing
Queen to g5 so crossing the play Queen
to g3 and it was in this position that
night King resigned the game there is
nothing you can do here the idea is that
after something like Queen to a fate of
course this loses immediately you get
rid captures and now there's really no
normal moves
Queen kept twin has to capture and Queen
captures here poor Queen does dare to
capture you can simply
any other move and then Queen captures
is again checkmate because the queen is
now pinned so you do get this funny
formation again the chess a threesome as
we do call it here on this channel so
yeah basically that's it
Carson winning the leaches title arena
for the fourth time winning three
thousand and two hundred thousand
dollars and donating it back to Lee
chess so a very nice thing I mean it's
not like he donated it he first has to
give someone else the opportunity just
to win this because he already wanted
for the first time so we'll see if he
will be able to win it every time
because this time it was it was somewhat
close one hundred and sixty eight points
and grandmaster clever tactics but fail
160 points so very close so yeah and if
anyone has any idea who the night king
is do share in the comments I'm sure
everyone would love to know who this
grandmaster is and also maybe who
grandmaster clever tactics but fail is
do share in the comments so yeah
I would like to thank Richard grease
William greening Christopher manney's
Patrick Kelly and Yosef to itself for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video from your suggestions
thank you